to the ghost of hot ones guests past
I'm sorry for my my judgment from home
you were Brave
and I get it
hey what's going on everybody for first
week Feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today we're joined by Emma Chamberlain
she's an internet Juggernaut turned
coffee Mogul and fashion icon check out
our YouTube page for everything from a
la mode European travel Vlogs to swap
meet shopping hauls like me you can
check out chamberlaincoffee.com for all
your coffee needs added the cake batter
blend to my cart this morning and
finally of course anything goes I'm a
Chamberlain wherever you get your
podcast Emma Chamberlain welcome to the
show thank you for me I know that spicy
hummus is like a part of your everyday
diet what's going through your head
right now as you prepare to take on the
hot ones Gauntlet I actually feel really
confident because I was telling you
before we started recording
I've done this before my friends and I
went to a hot sauce store in La a few
years ago and bought your whole lineup
and tried it on our own so I'm like
I'm chilling like this is gonna be the
easiest interview of my life I can't
wait let's do it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
oh my God why am I like shaking I'm
I know
no it'll be okay it'll be fine
delicious
so good
[Music]
giving us the vegan Wing recommendation
thank you Natalie yes
so you open your Vogue beauty secrets
video by saying that you've always
wanted to do one whether it's cooking
with Josh Weissman or playing soccer
with Kevin Hart what's the thing that
makes you excited about doing a YouTube
video that's not on your own channel
something that feels
real
and something that I think is fun too
because I feel like video creating in
general should be fun obviously there is
sort of oh like we want this to perform
well we want this to do well we want
this to get a lot of views blah blah
blah there's a lot of that and you can't
always Escape that but I think when a
show or a series is just like rooted in
fun in some way that's what excites me
and like sharing information having a
cool conversation
that inspires me
[Music]
that was like just delicious I didn't
even feel anything so I'm ready for
number two this is the tropicante here
in the two spot
hmm
so good nice little happy dance there I
love it here we go I mean I love hot
sauce so
we haven't ruined it for you yet exactly
exactly later might not love it anymore
so one thing you and I share about
putting videos on the Internet is an
all-consuming obsession with the edit
quick shout out to hot ones editor Colin
Higgins is somebody who's been copied ad
nauseum across the web what is the
editing Trope that you're happy to have
birth to the masses and then can you
give us another one that you never want
to see again honestly like
my editing style when I first sort of
started becoming known on the internet a
little bit was super fast-paced super
crazy like you know zooming in zooming
out you know like jump cut jump cut like
crazy speed right because that's kind of
what kept people's attention
there was a time and a place for that
but now I can't stand it and that's why
like more recently I've been like let's
slow it down yeah very melancholy
totally and I'm I'm proud of that being
sort of a new thing like let's
cool things down a little bit you know
do you have a favorite voice effect I
kind of love the echo yeah me too it's
hilarious it never I know you guys do
like the echo we love the echo yes it's
fun
[Music]
I'm like ready for the pain and I know
I'm gonna regret saying that but I'm
feeling too good right now
and then not to lead the witness but I
love this hot sauce that one is so good
it's like going into it's like taking a
bite out of pizza or something it's like
eating a delicious pizza it is pizza I'm
taking this one home actually you can
have them all
but that's the one yeah that's delicious
and it has a cat on it so that makes me
happy
so in the same way that I'm inextricably
linked to Wings you are connected to
Coffee which you've been slurping down
in prolific quantities since you first
started making YouTube videos in
layman's terms what is the difference
between like a gas station one dollar
cup of coffee and then the five dollar
cup that you get at some like third wave
Coffee Cafe
so not to be like a complete nerd about
it be a nurse feel like how people are
with wine and they're like no no it's
like melt this one's really like melon
and trees I mean I'm not fully like that
with coffee but you know when you drink
gas station coffee it's like one note
it's just like
it's like a suggestion of a coffee
flavor and then a really good cup of
coffee is like
oh my God first sip it's like oh it's
kind of nutty and then it's like oh but
now it's kind of bitter and then it's
like and it's a journey I would say the
journey for a nice cup of coffee is just
much longer and and it's more you know
exciting you want to go back and have
more and also you don't need to add a
bunch of milk and sugar to it to make it
taste interesting
F Mary kill whole milk oat milk nut milk
okay
Mary almond milk
F the oat milk
kill the whole milk
how about you
have to ask out of that whole milk oh
yeah
right no do not have issues no you know
what I I'm going with the whole milk I
just thought that that was like a funny
thing to say that was just a reaction I
was like no Emma that was a bit like you
[ __ ] it up and now we have to move on
love you okay
foreign
talking and like stalling yeah me too
that's how the show
oh my God this one's so good too
now it's in my teeth though
easier than maybe the first time you did
it honestly um
this is the first one where I'm like
okay
I get what the show is about you know
what I mean like okay
that happens yeah
so believe it or not there's nothing we
like more here on hot ones than a deep
dive into interior design and Decor in
your recent house tour and Architectural
digest is one of the best in recent
memory one time I got in a fight with a
designer quick shout out to Ren because
he wouldn't let me put a TV above the
fireplace or he was fighting with me
about a TV above the fireplace what's
the thing that caused the most tension
between you and your design team it's
actually funny because I luckily am not
a huge TV person and so I remember there
was like a conversation about my
fireplace and like hey are we gonna put
a TV there and I was like No And they
were like oh
love you like thank god
um biggest fight they don't like the TV
above the fireplaces no no they hate it
yeah because it completely and I kind of
get it because it does sort of ruin it
but it's also like we live right that's
that's what that's why I was like listen
dude because he was he was talking to
he's like well what about like a formal
dining room here I was like yeah don't
try to tell me what my lifestyle is like
this is the heartbeat of this entire
apartment you know like I watch a lot of
college football and that's like why I'm
getting the biggest TV ever above that
fireplace don't tell me how to live my
life Ryan amen
[Music]
halfway point oh this one see there's
two sides on this Wing one that has a
bunch of the sauce one that doesn't I'm
choosing the one that does have a lot of
the sauce on it there you go because I'm
loyal to the show remember this respect
okay respect let's do it
um
that is so good too wait
hmm
[Music]
that's one of those kind of complicated
flavor
yeah a chili oil base which is a little
unique for us over here I mean honestly
like it [ __ ] hurts really bad
I will be honest
but it's so [ __ ] good that like this
is so good yeah just maybe on a smaller
scale like drizzling it on top of like
something right not having like a whole
like bite of it big big bite
really delicious though
what so far has been the greatest
Triumph of your cooking tutorials and
then can you give us your biggest fail
my biggest Triumph like making nut milk
I think I'm going to delete that one but
it was a huge success I didn't realize
that you could so easily make your own
nut milk tried it slayed it loved it I
haven't done it since but
good to know and my biggest fail was
probably
[Music]
like literally so many years ago I tried
to make coffee cake like this was like
one of my first videos
and it was just like so so disgusting
anything I made when I was like 16 was a
fail could not cook back then can you
give us one highlight and one low light
from hosting the red carpet at last
year's Mech gallon
okay a highlight
was
like accidentally having my first meme
Moment Like Whoa Jack
thank you Jack Harlow
um I still like have never spoken to him
about that so I think we could have a
fun bonding moment over that next time I
run into him
but the low light was this is so TMI and
gross I had a tonsil Stone do you know
what a tonsil Stone no I don't know what
it's oh it's so gross it's basically
like a buildup of like bacteria on your
tonsil that you can get if you have
allergies or like sinus drip whatever
and they like taste bad and like kind of
can smell bad too and I had one while
I'm supposed to be interviewing people
for four hours straight
like this close too
I was eating Altoids
I was eating Altoids providing a cover
yeah and that was like brutal for me I
was like freaking out in between each
one like I like what like is it bad like
whatever but we got through it we got
through it but that was shitty well you
know what speaking of you know the walls
closing in on you being pressed but
moving on are you ready to move to the
back half here let's go to the back
house
so this next one is the turmeric bomb
here in the sixth spot all right
[Music]
I think I need to start taking a little
smaller bites
because like I've been doing big ones
this whole time yeah time to slow down
so it's not every day that someone goes
from try on Thrift hauls at their
parents house to becoming vogue's
digital Muse and working with the likes
of Louis Vuitton and Levi's what's a
memory you have of Paris Fashion Week
being a zoolander-like parody of itself
okay
my favorite thing to witness and listen
I'm not
laughing at anyone be I would probably
do the same thing but also like maybe
we're laughing together I don't know
maybe I am making fun of them I don't
know
um
this whole sort of getting the right
moment for the IG story type of thing so
it's like
maybe it's at an after party or
something and a Paris fragment after
party and everybody's like you know like
dancing like whatever like you know
acting like they're having the best time
meanwhile like it's kind of a chill
after party and then like phones down
and it's just like
and I just feel like I see a lot of that
at Fashion Week where it's like
everyone's in on the same like same
hustle this same Hustle the same
illusion it's kind of like a really
magical moment in human like in society
like the fact that everybody comes
together to be like Fashion Week is the
best week ever you know what I mean and
it's like the fact that everybody's kind
of painting this picture together like
Community it is beautiful yeah
Cosmic dicks go
Disco
Cosmic disco let's do it
I went in for like a big bite and then
[Music]
this one's really bad
yeah it's like full [ __ ] like
it is a different sauce
we start to like kind of jump planes
here in the back half it like skips some
levels you know
no like we just like
holy [ __ ] for each one it was like
times two times two times it was like
times [ __ ] 14 with that one yeah well
wait till you get to the next one not to
leave the witness here yeah no
um
what distinguishes a good peanut butter
from a mediocre one and then what's your
go-to pro tip for making it from scratch
at home
Okay so
see now this is when you start to get
distracted by your pain and it's just
like
peanut butter oh what
um
for me a good peanut butter is
all natural
it's like changing the way my my my box
my voice box
unfortunately you damaged my voice box
um
I prefer like an all-natural just like
peanuts and salt
Vibe like that is the best and I think
the reason for that is is like I like
peanut flavor whereas like
when
um
like the
holy [ __ ] you can't think see this is
why you're an evil genius
like Jif peanut butter is like Too Fake
it tastes like icing like it's not
that's not peanut butter I want peanuts
and that's it and when you're making it
at home
add a little bit of vanilla bean wow is
that delicious and some dates it's
really good moving on well this next one
is the bomb Beyond insanity
I've tried this one actually yeah but I
don't think I
I don't remember I think this was
actually the hottest one I did when I
tried it at home so I don't even want to
touch it with my finger I feel like it's
bad okay let's do it let's do it
[Music]
[ __ ]
no this is when it gets [ __ ] serious
it's for real I can't even believe it
goes more than this
I can't even believe there's more than
this okay
what's the hardest influencer dollar to
make and what would you say is the
easiest
[Music]
oh
my God
it's like
[Music]
it's kind of like a relatively like
religious experience yeah you know what
sometimes you can get a little bit of a
high off of it
oh [ __ ] it hurts so fast and it's a
little trippy it gets a little trippy
okay
I'm like fully serving but I want you to
know and I want everyone back here to
know
I'm not scared so you shouldn't be sad
okay
I'm okay
but I I'm like gushing tears you have
just it's like the one
like it's like out of them believe them
it's out of a blue like this is a part
of the [ __ ] hot one Spiritual
Awakening
good
foreign
like I'm here for it okay
so the easiest
leave it it's part of it
I love it yes
no I mean it [ __ ] hurts so [ __ ]
bad
okay
um the easiest dollar
you make as an influencer I would say
would be
[Music]
like holding up a product on Instagram
taking a photo you know and posting it
being like hashtag ad
Fletcher's easy
um
I just wish people knew at home that
like when everybody's crying and like
everybody's like
can't get words out
that like this shit's serious right like
because I feel like even I when I used
to watch it I was like this shit's not
that serious like
you're a [ __ ]
and now I'm like no right I'm so sorry
um for everything
to the ghosts of hot ones guest pass to
the ghost of hot ones guest passed I'm
sorry for my my judgment from home you
were Brave
and I get it
[Music]
okay let's let's rock on this next one
is pucker butt's unique garlic
I don't consider myself like
I don't know I'm just feeling
particularly spiritual praying that God
knows what else is up there in these
trying times these trying times
foreign
[Music]
so your podcast anything goes with Emma
Chamberlain is an episodic thought
exercise where you Ponder questions that
range from how much privacy a celebrity
is entitled to to whether or not anyone
is actually cool as someone who's open
about the fact that their opinions
change all the time what's like the last
or most recent like bad take you've had
on your own podcast
I don't know to be honest like I don't
look at any of my anything I've ever
said
I almost throw it in the dumpster behind
me yeah
it's true right then but it might not be
true literally tomorrow and I try to
make sure everyone knows that so that
you know it's not like anyone's like
but I don't know what about that that
you said it's like no I'm always ebbing
and flowing baby and that's a good
that's a good place to be
what
are we going in
if you're ready are we last stabbing it
we're last stabbing it if you're ready
I'm just [ __ ] doing it
oh that's a good Shake
[Music]
how much are we doing here
that looks measured that is looking good
that is looking good yeah that's perfect
any more than that that is good
all right I'm just like taking my time
putting it back
taking my time I'll screw back on too
just for for you guys so it looks good
on the table
shout out to the crew
I'm not like stalking
all right and it's time to go cheers all
right cheers
[Music]
and while that settles nice long wind up
to close things out what I want to do is
we'll pray on your natural creative
instincts in aesthetic can you rearrange
the hot ones Gauntlet from favorite to
least favorite based entirely on the
artistic appeal of the labels
like which one I think is the most
aesthetic yeah aesthetically amazing
this is like actually my dream yeah of
an activity especially during my like
what I'm feeling right now although part
of me like wants to like
finish the wing to like really like do
it should be [ __ ] let's do it let's
go okay
what I'm so do I regret okay
okay I'm determined one more bite
incredible I'm not a baby and I want
everyone out there to know that I
[ __ ] came here and I [ __ ] did it
let them know this has been my dream
since I first started YouTube was to one
day come here and I'm [ __ ] finishing
the last week okay it was changing the
last one wait what yes
I always wanted to come on the show
because I've been obsessed with it since
it like literally came out and started
however long ago and I was like once I
[ __ ] go on hot ones
I like I can retire like that's always
been my thing
and so like I'm [ __ ] finishing the
wings okay
[Music]
Pico Rico with the cat your favorite
that cat is just so
has to go first it makes me want to buy
the hot sauce
I love when animals are on stuff next
we're gonna go with this one I really I
like the colors very inviting
not traditional but personal I love that
little branding
okay I really like it
I really like this one I mean it's you
guys so like
but I like it because it's simple and
effective and classic and that's exactly
what it is
for some reason it's going last like
don't want to offend anyone but I just
like feel like it reminds me of like
a Florida like Grandma
okay you know what [ __ ] him just zooming
through now here we go okay this one
reminds me of like so many this is like
the Burning Man Edition
the bomb it's effective and it's
accurate
final touches
final touches I'm committing to this oh
my God I'm done and there you have it
set it in stone and hang it in the
Louvre Emma Chamberlain taking on the
hot ones Gauntlet and living to tell the
tale now there's nothing left to do but
roll out the red carpet for you this
camera this camera this camera let the
people know what you have going on in
your life
um yes yes
thank you
um well I have a coffee company uh
chamberlaincoffee.com pick up some
coffee tea coffee and tea related
accessories I have a podcast anything
goes check it out new episodes all the
time every Thursday every week
um and sometimes I make YouTube videos
when my when it sets my soul on fire
thank you Sean what a day what a day
you did it that was so fun
what are you gonna tell your dad
that this shit's serious and and that I
saw in your face that you're there with
me right there with you you were there
with me oh my God I shouldn't touch
myself yeah be careful I did you made it
all the way to this point all the way up
that was so fun you had a good time
are you guys free for another hour let's
do it again
thank you so much for watching today's
video and hot ones fans I have a very
exciting announcement the hot ones Shake
Shack collab is finally here the hot
ones cheese fries the hot ones Burger
the hot ones chicken all made with a
shack sauce that includes hot ones the
classic along with the last dab it's
very spicy it's very delicious and it's
available for a limited time now through
the end of the year at Shake Shacks
Nationwide and via the Shake Shack app
be careful around your eyes and don't
forget to order a milkshake
[Music]